el examen de liszt incluye una encuesta
que pregunta a los alumnos cuántas horas
estudiaron para el examen el siguiente
diagrama de dispersión y su línea de
tendencia muestran la relación entre
cuantas horas estudiaron los alumnos y
su calificación en el examen la línea
ajustada para modelar los datos tiene
una pendiente cuyo valor es 15 aquí está
el diagrama de dispersión del que
hablábamos y esta es su línea de
tendencia la línea ajustada para modelar
a estos datos y lo que nos dice por
ejemplo este punto es que algún alumno
pasó entre media hora y una hora
estudiando y obtuvo una calificación un
poco menor a 45 por otro lado aquí este
alumno obtuvo una calificación menor a
65 puntos y estudio un poco menos de dos
horas
nos podemos ir al otro extremo por aquí
este alumno obtuvo 94 o 95 puntos y
estudió más de 4 horas
entonces ajustaron una línea a estos
datos y esa línea tiene una pendiente de
15 pero bueno incluso antes de leer las
posibles respuestas vamos a preguntarnos
cuál es la mejor interpretación de está
pendiente bueno pues si pensamos que
esta línea nos indica la tendencia y
observando este diagrama de dispersión
esta línea si parece representar la
tendencia de estos datos y entonces lo
que nos dice la pendiente de la línea es
que tanto aumenta la calificación
conforme aumenta la cantidad de horas de
estudio y en este caso como la pendiente
es 15 nos está diciendo que la
calificación aumenta aproximadamente 15
puntos por cada hora extra de estudio
que realicen los alumnos eso es lo que
nos está diciendo esta regresión lineal
es por ejemplo si empezamos por aquí con
media hora de estudio y aumentamos una
hora de estudio nuestra calificación
debería de aumentar aproximadamente 15
puntos en el eje horizontal estamos
aumentando una hora y en el eje vertical
15 puntos en fin así es como yo lo
interpretaría si nos basamos en esta
regresión lineal por cada hora de
estudio que aumentemos podemos esperar
aproximadamente un aumento de 15 puntos
en la calificación o bueno por lo menos
es bastante razonable esperar un aumento
de aproximadamente 15 puntos eso es lo
que estamos observando con esta
regresión lineal de estos datos pero
bueno ahora sí vamos a ver qué es lo que
nos dice en estas opciones advair veamos
la primera opción dice que el modelo
predice que los estudiantes que
obtuvieron cero de calificación
estudiaron en promedio 15 horas
y no para nada está definitivamente es
una opción incorrecta a ver vamos con la
segunda opción el modelo predice que los
estudiantes que no estudiaron tendrán
una calificación promedio de 15 puntos
me parece que tampoco dice eso el modelo
pero vamos a volver a verlo bueno pues
si creemos lo que dice este modelo
acerca de la relación entre el tiempo de
estudio y la calificación si lo
proyectamos en alumnos que no hayan
estudiado nada este modelo nos dice que
esos alumnos obtendrían una calificación
entre 35 y 40 así es que esta opción
también es incorrecta pero bueno vamos
con la tercera opción el modelo predice
que la calificación se incrementa en 15
puntos por cada hora adicional del
estudio y si definitivamente eso es lo
que estábamos pensando cuando estábamos
observando el modelo esto es lo que
quiere decir que la pendiente de la
línea de tendencia tenga un
valor de 15 si aumentamos una hora
adicional de estudio se incrementa la
calificación por 15 puntos pero bueno
también tenemos que ver qué dice la
cuarta opción y nos dice que el modelo
predice que el tiempo de estudio se
incrementa en 15 horas por cada punto
adicional en la calificación
esta opción definitivamente no porque el
tiempo de estudio es nuestra variable
independiente y la calificación es
nuestra variable dependiente esta opción
lo está diciendo al revés además de que
no esperamos un incremento de 15 horas
por cada punto adicional en la
calificación